[Music]
welcome to the british council learning
hub we're here to get you started and
show you where to get help if you need
it
step one the learning hub works best
with the most recent version of google
chrome
activities work best on a laptop pc or
mac
but don't worry if your child uses a
tablet or a phone they'll still be able
to complete the activities it's just
that the experience is better on a
larger screen step two
you will receive a welcome to the
learning hub email inviting you to set
up your child's account
click on the button or link to create a
password oh and keep this email safe you
may need to refer to it again in the
future
step 3 you will be taken to this page
where we will ask you to create a
password
choose something memorable to you and
your child using a mix of upper and
lower case letters
enter the new password twice and press
submit
step four now let's log on
at the bottom of your welcome to the
learning hub email you will find the web
address for your child's learning hub
your child's username
step 5 click on the web address this
will take you to your child's learning
hub for either primary plus or secondary
plus whichever course your child is
registered on
now enter your child's username and the
password you have created
now you're logged on your child can
access their course modules excellent
work don't worry if you forget your
password we all do
just click lost password on the home
page and follow the instructions on
screen so this is where you will need to
use your child's username
copy it from your welcome to the
learning hub email
paste it in the box on the lost password
page
follow the security check and reset your
password
if you have any problems on the learning
hub we have a special team of people to
help you do not worry and what's more
you can write to them in your own
language they will understand
simply hit the help button by the way
it's better to use the help button
rather than calling or emailing us
choose what you're having a problem with
then type your email address the one you
use to register for the course
add a brief description of what's wrong
don't forget you can write to us in your
own language
our team will respond in less than one
minute via email they will reply in
english so we recommend using google
translate to translate the text if you
prefer to read in your own language so
check your email we will have sent
instructions to solve the problem
if you still need help reply to the
email and our support team will give you
more help
it's best to join the live classes using
a laptop pc or mac
the live classes will be listed here
if your child is joining a live class
it's a good idea to follow this
checklist
ensure your child is in a quiet place
with no distractions
log on to the learning hub a few minutes
in advance
check your internet connection
check your tech we recommend that you
search for zoomtest and follow the
instructions on screen
when it's time simply click join
[Music]
and your child will enter a waiting room
the teacher will check the identity of
your child using their first name and
the first letter of their last name once
the checks are complete the teacher will
start the live class
remember if you have problems with this
click the help button and follow the
steps we just covered
to help you log on to the learning hub
easily it's a good idea to bookmark the
british council learning hub website you
do it like this
click the star on the address bar
then click save
child protection is so important to us
to keep everyone safe and to ensure that
everyone feels valued and comfortable we
have some golden rules that we ask all
students to follow
find them in our code of conduct section
if your child forgets their password
just before class and you are not
available to reset it a member of staff
at the teaching centre will be able to
help
for this reason we recommend that your
child has the british council teaching
center phone number to hand just in case
and that's it you're all set to go
watch our other videos to find out what
your child will be doing on the learning
hub
bye
you